should we have a code of ethics similar
to the ones we find for doctors and
lawyers for CEOs of course we should CEO
should be held accountable just like
doctors and lawyers for doctors we have
the Hippocratic oath stemming from
Hippocrates in ancient Greece real
lawyers we have the bar exam the
Hippocratic oath tells doctors first do
no harm it seems that modern corporate
executives don't follow first do no harm
CEO should not have an ethical code this
answer may seem odd it looks like the
perfect solution since a lot of the Cure
and economic miam has been caused by
unethical actions but the code is not
the answer simply because we already
have one it's called the law it is
probably going to be really hard making
a code like that since every business is
different and you can't really make
everybody follow the same thing a common
characteristic shared by doctors and
lawyers is that of serving others in
society this is not directly to for CEOs
their goal is to make money so yes we do
need a code of ethics for CEOs but not
one like the race for doctors and
lawyers company executives should
provide the leadership and the example
for the company the ethics can be summed
up in one word integrity the main issue
here is a corporation is a non living
entity that has one sole purpose and
that's to create money for the owners
and its shareholders maybe what you on
Davos could be talking about and
discussing is probably a little bit
better governance a little bit better
oversight and dare I say a little bit
more regulation seems to me at least on
this part of the world that we have
deregulated ourselves into a great big
hole it's going to be a little while
before we get out of it this hope the
business should actually come from the
World Economic Forum that again I think
it's something that the World Economic
Forum can convene a group of experts and
by World Economic Forum 2010 for there
to be a press release an executive
report that would be issued to the
public that this is the oath of business
that we have come up with and that could
be the legacy of the World Economic for